okay um so posted a lot of videos just
because a lot of people are sending me
videos which is good that's what you're
supposed to do other otherwise we're
just watching from afar like what is
that about that's almost like uh a
voyerism you know something it's really
I think we're just too afraid to put
ourselves out there um well that's a
life lived in fear and fear is the only
true sin there's no way I'm going to be
able to do II CQ uh or Divine communion
through that way you have to put
yourself out
there um especially if you're going to
take the time you're going to you're
going to come into this Hermitage of
mine uh and you're going to want to
learn this stuff you got to share the
video so I I really am glad that more
and more people are doing this um
and I have posted some kind of generic
videos on uh a lot of the common uh
mistakes and in need of further
refinement on the cou drill set and now
what I'd like to do is go into the
particulars like for this person okay
and that's where we're going to go now
but do not forget all the stuff that I
said in the generic videos they apply to
everyone so for
example um you should continually try to
release muscle tension um more and more
and more and then the little caveat
special attention to the lower half of
the body and then two continually try to
reduce a movement of any kind uh to get
rid of that more and more and more
okay um so this one is for Karen and
Noah we were watching your videos and I
put them to my dasi to see how much
they're processing what I'm teaching
them and I think they landed uh very uh
accurately on the pointers that I would
give to you and so these are the
pointers I'd give to you and they were
able to come up with them as well okay
and um what we want to point out is that
there's several drills in the set and
while there's overlap they don't all do
the same thing okay um and also let's
note that the drill set is a beginner
Set uh and so there's stuff to do after
that uh they're not the end all by any
means it's just how do I get people not
on my mat committed to me uh to learn
that there's something else out there
than what they've been told by Emperors
who don't wear close that that's what
that drill set is okay um
so you have to do all of them you can't
just do the first one or the first two
or the first three you have to get to
the last one I think it goes up to six
or seven okay uh because each one does
something different and you should do
each one the way it is prescribed there
not not trying to do the same thing for
each one okay so um what we noticed is
that the first let me say this Karen
your catching skills are really good I
liked your posture and I liked how
relaxed you are um so I would say hey
keep keep experimenting with this um the
the truth will reveal itself to you
you're you're in the right direction uh
Noah I would come to the caveat of um
more and more release more more
relaxation less muscle tension pay
attention to the tension in the lower
legs and the feet and then for both of
you I would try to get uh reducing the
arm movement okay try to get rid of
that then pull out the generic pointer I
gave in the last several videos uh
recently posted your person has to push
they have to be
driving um they can't be ready to go
backwards okay
so if we understand that each drill is
different and we understand those things
now we can see how is each drill
different okay so we do have uh for
example this a static drill right and uh
something to note here not not really of
this but this you should you have to pay
attention that I'm wearing socks on the
mat and there's no friction here is
there's no bracing angle okay I'm I'm
I'm I'm on ice gapes when we're doing
this stuff okay but force is going to go
down not not backwards on me so force is
down okay so we have the ones where
we're static and I release the tension
paying particular attention to the back
foot we have another one where I come
onto the back foot and then shift onto
the front foot that's just what that one
is boom and then shift on to the front
foot that is all that is then we have
one where we
catch so I catch him onto the back
foot and project
catch but on that
on that catch one my hands don't
catch and that
meaning wait you're fine slow it down so
I can talk I don't catch
externally and then project through a
ground path on my extending arms my arms
are doing the same thing as they did in
the boat rowing one my arms don't move
so right now Karen when you catch you
catch
externally and it works because Noah is
only penetrating to the cats reconcile
this young conflict scoot
back then it'll
work uh Chris is driving where if I
catch and he's going to push me back if
I catch extra
and then try to project on him I go
backwards okay so um I'll make that
point as the UK but I think Chris made
that point um when you
go into uh drill
[Music]
seven you're catching externally but it
only works because Noah only penetrated
to here but there's no spinal
displacement
there you go as fast as you want it
doesn't
work but so spiral
displacement is through
so I can't go
here if you
if you is truly spinally displacing the
catch is
internal catch
is
internal now between this last
one and the catch one here you do have
the internal one where you are going
towards
him there's no
there's no way you can externally catch
on that one talk so in other words I
can't have my hands going because I'm
going to get jammed if he's still
pushing at
me so it's it's a internal
catch
and and that is the one that you take
into this
one internal
the internal catch not an external catch
so to help bring this to the
surface um I would do the one where
you're going forward
and uh I would do the last one and
making sure that no is actually finally
displacing
so that you can't externally go to a
neutral
y okay we don't want that in this drill
St okay so
again uh there there is an external
catch it's not with my arms
though no that one I catch onto the back
foot okay catch onto the back foot
that's the one I'm not saying however we
don't do these these ex these external
catches we do do that okay it's just not
in the
drill in the drill set and then as you
move
forward there is
one where you're going
forward and it is impossible to
externally catch that
one so um and the reason why is the the
catch or the conflict resolution it
happens inside it doesn't happen on the
outside because we're going to do
something else with the
outside um meaning uh I'm not going to
go here and then find Center this is
something we're working on with with our
dishing here so they they will do an
external heel then they'll find Center
okay and we don't want that we want
center right from the start we want to
see want to se the Center on
contact as noted in the Keon from
yesterday at contact boom I'm bringing
him forward into tenin Naga we we're
doing something other than getting out
of the way and then finding center okay
and in order to seize the center on
contact the conflict is reconciled
internally his Y is going through me
okay okay and the drill where you go
forward that's the only way you can do
it okay so as he's coming as I'm walking
in he's just going out
okay I don't want to stop and then go
that would not sop the drill okay so I
don't brace and then push him off and
then act like I'm walking okay that
that's not the
drill the drill is that I'm just walking
no
walk
walk no
walk okay
um here we go we're going to try all
right uh now we'll address the uh the
other drill which is a great drill but
here I'll repeat the general caveat made
in the last several videos you should be
ever on guard for external elements
creeping their way into your drill
okay
um so as you're doing
as as you're doing this drill
[Music]
here you're going here into this drill
into that throw that thr
okay um uh try to
remember I don't do an external
yield uh we showed how that is not
effective when we increase the intensity
uh in one of those videos uh and
actually Chris was here for that one you
you're just going to get shut down so uh
his elbow got pinned one time against
his rib cage okay you can't do ex you
can't do external yields like everyone
in iido
thinks um that that was my point this
they're wrong you you externally yield
on true spinal displacement you gave the
opening for the true spinal displacement
you're it's just a matter of time you're
going to lose your toast okay um
so there's not an external yield there
is a center seizure at the beginning and
that is a form of II hence my phrase
ien and the adhesion is is a controlling
element that determines the rate of uh
penetration of UK and also the degree of
penetration hence when we were doing uh
tensin nag it's not that I got out of
the way and let him in you're bringing
him in
[Music]
bring bringing them in that's what
you're doing there's a feels a pull
coming in okay um so that's what you're
doing here on the center seizure right
from the beginning and you can decide
whether you're going to make him go
around or whether you're going to make
him go
out right or whether you're going to
make him go this way that that's all
a
e e
it's all a a seizure not a getting out
of the way okay so back to the first
point our catches are not external
catches that that's not what we're
trying to
do um so likewise when you do this drill
you don't you're not just getting out of
the way way until you can push
again so one of the videos you sent is
we get out of the way and then we push
again uh Noah was doing this more
obviously get out of the way and then
you can push again on the center that
you're
feeling that is a phase of learning I
let my people do it for a very long time
because at least they're learning center
and they're learning where's neutral
young um so I'm not saying go off of it
for Noah um but I would probably uh for
you Karen I would I would probably make
you go past this phas okay and so it's
not that I
yield externally and then project that
that's not what's
happening what's happening is seizure
move seizure move seizure move seizure
move and the
projection the projection is loaded from
the seizure then you get CU bounces off
okay so
likewise it's not that I get out of the
way and then then push on the center
that's not what's happening he's driving
but I control the rate so he can open
his grip and I have an adhesion there
okay and I am moving his
[Music]
Center the same way that I move his
Center this way I'm moving his Center I
now move it in the EOP
P so the first thing the second
thing don't externally get out of the
way seee the center second thing is stay
in the
center don't come around it on top of it
onto his
shoulder your energy just like I'm here
okay I'm not touching his Center
just like I'm here but I can move his
Center it it doesn't matter I can be up
high and I can still move his
Center are you go and move his move his
Center that CES the center so
likewise I know my hand is at shoulder
height but I don't push at his
shoulder I have to push at his
Center that's what I'm
doing so
sees move
Center then I let him back in when I let
him back in I don't do another external
deviation sees Center and then I'm
moving
in what I'm doing
doing I move
him that same Center but I move it into
the in the the outward spiral so I don't
just get out of the way come around him
no I turn him one way Center turns and I
turn him the other
way just that transition part wh
Center and
then
Center not get out out of the way and
then he
HS boom
Center next
part khole requires a back break
fall so he has to be going
forward so this move doesn't go
here do the technical part Center
boom move he goes this way
this
way e
so if we do this
se you can
see what this drill is doing more aside
from all those things so yes it's an
extension of the cyu drill set then the
iy drill set but it is the arm patterns
inward outward
and the qua
coordination so when I move
qua
qua and
likewise don't stay in his
shoulder quw Center Center
boom same thing it's not that I get out
of the
way I move him moving him moving him and
here's the part where this energy here
on his head makes him go forward and
then
around qu moves qu moves
forward
boom too often when we move our feet we
stop moving our
qua right here no quaw moving
[Music]
move
qua came back move qua
qua Okay add those please um only do the
x pattern the true x pattern if your UK
can take the
um but you can get very close to it um
without having to do it so here I didn't
really do I didn't do it okay um but
eventually get there because you learn a
lot about uh your ability to internalize
y aspect if you can displace somebody's
base with your base do you see it's not
so easy um because of the force
equations that are involved in base
displacement so basically to displace a
base you're going through the heaviest
part of that person um and that'll tell
you how good you are at internalizing
yangong or whether you're just
contesting because you're not going to
be you you basically you're I don't
weigh I don't weigh more than Chris so
to displace Chris is I can't outy him
it's not possible okay and so you learn
something but don't do the x pattern
where you take the leg out until the UK
can totally do it okay and sometimes
some UK will never be able to do it who
car who cares really okay all right
but uh one of the things is that as I'm
in the center his Center and I stay at
his Center the whole time here the same
thing goes here don't try to just move
his head just like here don't try to
just move his shoulder
you you're moving the center of his body
the center is what you're moving okay so
when you go to
throw no you feel the the energy and you
move the
center what you're doing you pull on the
center in this
case move the center move the
center e
move the center okay uh don't go for the
easy Bend so you might have you guys do
have some f stuff in in you so your UK
is going to recognize this they want to
go
backwards but you adhere bring them
forward okay and then they want to go
down but you're going to stay with that
and adhere he wants to go down but you
you pull on the
center okay you feel that those the
center is getting moved into the throw
not I'm going around it so I don't
go I don't go around I don't go around
the center into the shoulder and
likewise I don't go around the center
into the
head I move the
center and I move so I'm going to turn
it bring it forward and in I move it and
now same thing here I'm moving Cent
move the heaviest part of okay okay